One of the reasons that the gun debate
in this country is so contentious is
that there's very little good data on
who owns guns and what share of guns
used in crimes are illegal guns.
And part of the reason there's not good
data is because the debate is so
contentious in the first place.
But you know,
one proposal that I like a lot is to
create kind of a national firearms
safety administration,
something like the National Highway
Traffic Safety Administration Nitsa,
which correlates transportation data.
So if we want to know about what really
causes,
you know,
there's still 30 to 35,000
traffic fatalities a year,
that's a lot considering how much we
drive.
It's not that much,
but it's,
that's a lot of death.
The more we know about how every
accident happens,
the better we can do at preventing.
Similarly with something like guns,
the more we know about how guns are
used,
how they get in the hands of the people
who use them for crime.
The vast majority of guns are never,
ever,
ever used in any crime.
So,
you know,
um,
that I think is a really useful way to
look at what data can do.
I think right now we have people on the
gun on one side of the gun debate
saying,
you know,
uh,
we need our guns for whatever and uh,
you know,
leave us alone.
The other side saying,
ah,
all guns are terrible and you need to
take them all away.
Um,
both those arguments would seem to be a
little bit naive,
but we can't really get to a better
place because we don't have the data.
I,
you know,
I grew up in,
I personally grew up in a gun culture.
I grew up in upstate New York where most
families had guns for hunting,
target practice,
whatever.
The vast majority of people I knew never
use their guns for any crime.
Most laws that we make to protect people
from guns are usually ignored by the
criminals and obeyed by the law abiding
people.
And so I think that if you had better
data,
there'd be no one more in favor of it
than law abiding gun owners because they
don't want to be smeared and lumped in
with the criminals who use guns.
So that's where data,
um,
can be kind of different tool in the
arsenal when you're trying to make
better policy or public policy because
otherwise you're just kind of shouting
at each other with your ideology rather
than understanding how people actually
behave.
Okay.